now good evening thanks for joining us
here at six i'm denise feldas and i'm
david charns the family of the students
seen in that viral video getting beat up
by another student in the classroom is
now getting legal representation they
want to know how ccsd could let this
escalate to physical assault victoria
saha joins us now live from las vegas
high school on eastern near hollywood
where the attack happened with what the
family hopes is going to come out of
this victoria
yeah that assault was recorded and went
viral on social media the family has now
hired an attorney and the aclu of nevada
is looking into if there was a pattern
of bullying from the very same student
i'm not going to show you the video to
protect the victim but i can describe to
you what happened
a 15 year old was seen doing school work
when another student approached her from
behind and continued to hit her in the
back of the head knocking her
unconscious no one stepped in to help
either a teacher was heard telling the
attacker to stop the aclu now says when
the student was being escorted out she
grabbed her bag and hit the unconscious
student one more time hitting her a
total of 30 times now an investigation
is being done by the aclu and the family
attorney robert lankford to find out why
the student wasn't stopped and why the
victim wasn't helped
they're scared
they want to understand why this
happened
and they want to understand why people
have ignored them for nearly two weeks
um no response from the school district
no meaningful response from the school
district um
it has been a comedy of of errors
i was told the victim was left at the
school after the attack and had to wait
for her mom to come and take her to the
hospital she still has some health
issues and has not gone back to school
as for the other student accused in the
attack she was cited however we don't
have the answers at this time if she was
permitted to go back to school the aclu
is concerned because with this case as
they say when the student regained her
consciousness
the school staff reportedly told her to
call her mom to tell her what happened
however the aclu has reached out to the
school district to find out exactly what
happened that day and they're still
waiting for a report reporting from las
vegas high school tonight victoria saha
live local now the